so what we're making today is a shrimp
and shermulla sauce over a bed of
couscous drew so what you have here is
some chicken stock you can use plain
water as well and we're gonna pour in
that couscous give it a good stir just
like drew did i'm gonna pop in some salt
and then pop the cover in and turn it
off forget about it so now we're gonna
move on to the shermoula sauce it is
this wonderful north african
herb sauce you basically have everything
i promise you in your pantry to make
this i'm gonna move that so we have
chopped cilantro and chopped parsley a
little bit of coriander cumin
red chili flake the pantries just given
us today smoked paprika hot paprika and
a little bit of salt we're gonna mix
that all together i love a hungarian
paprika and then we're gonna micro zest
a little bit one garlic one garlic clove
wow that really zested super quickly
we're going to pour in that olive oil
drew i'm going to give this a mix
you got this keep on mixing
okay ready and this is really this sauce
guys is amazing it's like punchy it's
verdant it's like just really really
beautiful and it's super super addictive
so you're gonna mix that in the last two
things um is your citrus and we're gonna
add that in a little bit i only like to
add my citrus to my sharmulla right
before when i'm gonna use it is that
because it'll like cook ferment it'll
basically start to discolor
the
the sauce a little bit and i really want
to make sure that it's as bright and
beautiful as possible so now we have a
pan
about a tablespoon of olive oil
you got your peeled and deveined shrimp
and i am a good peeler and de veiner if
anybody knows you're so quick thank you
i really applied myself i mean it's
amazing so give it like
you need peeling and deveining give it
to me
give your shrimp a shake so that it's
all on one layer
and then we're going to season it
through with salt
and a little bit of cracked black pepper
and so just let that shrimp go
okay so what we're gonna do here so this
is kind of a specialty pantry item it's
called preserved lemon if you don't have
it you can use regular lemon but it's
actually a really easy and fun kitchen
project to make
it's basically you take a lemon you put
it in a jar you put it in a salt
solution you make some slits and the
lemon basically starts to essentially
pickle itself which is really nice um
and then you can add it into all your
sauces we have it here in our shrimp
it's wonderful in salads as well and
then drew
right on cue we're gonna flip that
shrimp flip that shrimp flip that shrimp
and as you can see
it's starting to get really nice real
hard time
that color is really good yeah this
color is perfect it smells really great
and you really don't want to overcook
your shrimp people don't like to
overcook a shrimp i don't mind i like my
i like my
my fish and meat a little tough or i
like it raw i'm an extremist i don't
know what to say
all right how long we have all right so
that's probably three more minutes oh
perfect we've got plenty of time
so
shrimp is really great for when you're
like doing a quick and easy dish this
sauce we're going to use the two way so
we're only going to put half in half and
the reason drew so you can use it as a
marinade for like fish and for meat but
the reason why i don't like to use it as
a marinade for this is because i'm
searing that shrimp and i don't want the
herbs to burn right i want to keep that
vibrancy don't let those are burnt
drew you should have water right beside
you yes i do so we're making a little
bit of a pan sauce and i'm going to pour
that in all the water
let's do half of that water for now
i really like this uh this call and
repeat thing it's kind of what we do in
our own kitchen
and you're basically gonna let that go
and cook two minutes
i'm gonna give it a quick taste this
really is pilar and in the kitchen she's
casual and i look nuts
this is so true to our life so maybe
give your sauce a little bit of a quick
taste room
um
and i'm gonna add a little bit of lemon
juice on there
lemon juice in the shrimp got it
just a little bit oh my gosh all right
okay now we're plating central i was not
expecting that i'm going to turn that
off
so right at this point drew the coo
sorry but like wow wow in a good way
yes all right so the couscous is all
steamed and you're going to fluff it
with a fork
and the reason why i use i like to use a
fork is because then it doesn't mush
things up yeah don't use a spoon don't
use the spoon
crush the little tiny balls beautiful um
nobody wants that one minute left we're
plating up julie
you got this
chill it's nice it's chill it's easy
how you doing drew
you know what i'm doing really good yeah
actually and then basically please do
not forget all that beautiful sauce that
you worked so hard on
you son of a
you got this yeah
oh okay i'm doing like a thing where i'm
getting the sauce
all over the thing
and then
and then i'm gonna do my shrimp because
i know it's gonna splatter everywhere
and plating is a part of my
important like i i take pride in my
plating i take a lot of pride in my
plating
that looks beautiful
and then don't forget to dollop your
fresh shermoula oh
there's there's no one right away
[Applause]
[Music]
you